are you gonna do something i should yeah
you should
and the only way he'll respect you is if
you try to destroy him because in your
position that is exactly what he would
try to do
yeah
i made
copies of a few key documents related to
all that stuff in case i got into any
trouble at all so
yeah i would just think like anybody
would be wise to keep me in a good role
ah succession the 20-hour experiment
exploring whether you can create a show
populated exclusively with unlikable
characters and still make the audience
care about what happens to them 20 hours
and counting because there are new
episodes coming next week when season 3
debuts and by the end of season 2 i
would say that the experiment has been a
success today i'm gonna do a refresher
video if you didn't have time to do a
re-watch or if you just can't get enough
of these roy family slime puppies of
course this video will contain spoilers
if you haven't watched the first two
seasons if you're just a viewer of my
channel and you're curious about
succession i definitely recommend it the
first season does take some time to get
its feet underneath it but it ends
strong and then the show continues to
improve through the second season where
it all comes together at the end and the
season 3 reviews that are out there all
sound pretty positive the big question
you might have is why do you want to
watch a bunch of awful people and this
isn't a review but i'll say real quick
that it's written well and there's a lot
of different routes to get into what's
going on you have family drama you have
black comedy you have wealth porn if
that's your thing amazing locations high
stakes business maneuvering all propped
up by stellar performances across the
board and some pretty solid social
satire to boot if i were to cobble some
words together i would say that
succession gives you a relatable dose of
humanity without humanizing the goals
behind the drama in other words you can
relate to the situations that the
unrelatable characters find themselves
in season 2 ends with one of those who
hasn't found themselves in a situation
where you're trapped with your family
and it's not easy to get away the roys
can't get away because they're on their
daddy's super yacht and while everyone's
coming together to try to figure out
what to do about the cruise ship
controversy no one here is safe and
everyone involved arrives with different
things on their minds conor and willa
are fresh off opening night of the play
she wrote and he financed which seems
destined for a lackluster reception shiv
is coming off what i guess you would
call a victory for the family where she
convinced the sexual assault victim who
was going to testify not to go through
with it in an effort to spice things up
with her husband she's arranged a
threesome with one of the employees that
works on the yacht roman is coming off
of a hostage situation more or less that
came out of a meeting that he set up in
an effort to get the financing to take
the company private kendall arrives in a
pretty good place he had the strongest
showing at the congressional hearings
and he's got naomi pierce with him as
his companion greg solidifies his place
once again as the outsider by not
realizing that sails out means nails out
and he's got a nail fungus to deal with
on top of his terrible performance at
the hearing that underlines the
situation that logan roy finds himself
in and sets the table for what they all
end up on this boat to do on his way
there logan gets a call where he learns
that the position of some of his big
shareholders is that he should step down
to me it never seems like he considers
this even later when he throws it out as
an option in front of his family but
we'll come back around to that the deal
is the family's still in the middle of
the proxy fight after the takeover that
kendall set in motion before he had to
pull back after killing the waiter in
the car crash at the end of the first
season the shareholder meeting's coming
up and logan says he needs one
meaningful skull to wave which is to say
a sacrifice of someone important to take
the fall for the cruiser's cover-up
logan lays it out there and then the
characters all take time to discuss who
should be the one to take the fall which
involves everyone getting their names
thrown out there to have everyone
discuss why they'd be a good candidate
right in front of them all of the
non-family characters are at risk roman
goes after frank and then he defends
jerry who he's got this secret
relationship going on with but in the
end they decide it has to be somebody in
the family
as i mentioned logan offers himself up
kendall's quick to jump in and say that
it won't work though primarily for
stability after rhea left when she found
out that logan definitely knew what was
going on with cruz's and had no problem
lying to her about it conor offers
himself up because he needs money which
we'll come back to and at one point it
feels like tom is the one that's gonna
get it because he was actually complicit
with destroying the documents and he did
a terrible job at the hearing in the
process of deciding a few things happen
the way they got here was that roman
decided he didn't trust the people who
were gonna back their play to go private
it's a move that seems to earn him some
points with his father even though it
takes an out for the company off the
table in general roman appears to come
out of nearly being a hostage stronger
than when he went in and he even throws
the idea out there of treating each
other better to his siblings but they
mock the idea and it ends there in the
last ditch effort kendall and logan meet
with stewie to make him a generous offer
which he refuses while they're gone tom
and shiv have some alone time and he
comes clean about how unhappy he is in
the marriage after she tried to assure
him that she wouldn't let anything
happen to him he makes it clear that he
wasn't okay with finding out that shiv
wanted an open relationship on their
wedding night and how he now wonders if
the sad he'd be without her would be
less than the sad he would get from
being with her that marks the end of her
chances to take over as ceo as later she
loses points when she goes to logan to
ask him not to use tom as the sacrifice
things don't go much better for the
other roy's not named logan connor hits
his dad up for a hundred million to help
with things after he refuses to help
with positive reviews for willa's play
he has to endure being crushed in the
process and agree to drop out of the
presidential race logan makes kendall
send naomi away saying he wasn't
properly informed and that he just
doesn't want ken on drugs it's the last
in a long line of awful things he's had
to endure this season starting with
getting pulled out of rehab and then
being forced to go into the house of the
family of the kid that died and it all
sets things up nicely for the end logan
arrives at his decision and tells
kendall even though he did so well at
the hearings he's gonna have to be the
face and that they'll create a press
conference where he can admit that he
knew everything directed the cover-up
and that it went no higher kendall
accepts this and then asked his father
if he ever thought he could do the ceo
job he says that he's not a killer he
stresses you have to be a killer and
then ken throws it out there that maybe
he deserves it for the boy who died and
logan tells him to forget that it's
nothing there was no real person
involved echoing the language that was
used for covering up the cruise ship
crimes ken assures everyone he'll be
okay and then he leaves to go back to
new york with greg he arrives at the
press conference to read the prepared
statement after describing why he's
there he drops a butt the butt hurt
around the world and goes off script
calling logan a malignant presence a
bully and a liar and that he was fully
personally aware of these events for a
number of years he points out that his
father always kept tight control over
everything that happened and that he
would never let settlements of millions
of dollars and payments go out to these
people without knowing about it and
kendall has those documents from greg to
prove it
back on the yacht the family's watching
and you see logan's face it's almost as
if he starts to smile sitting there
seeing his son become a killer he did
the thing that it didn't seem like any
of them would be able to do go against
their dad and really try to bring his
reign to an end kendall had tried to do
it before and we saw how that played out
he spent most of the season as a
punching bag completely cowed and that
kept the others in line everything fell
into place and greg holding on to those
documents finally paid off of course
logan won't go down without a fight his
smile led some viewers to guess that
this might have been his plan all along
i tend to think it's more of a callback
to that season one clip i opened the
video with that he just couldn't help
enjoy seeing his son do what he would
have done if the situation was reversed
i mean i see where people are coming
from and you can kind of make it work if
you go back and look at it that way but
based on how we've seen logan handle
things leading up to this point i think
it would be somewhat out of character he
uses his money his power and his
influence to get what he wants and
everything sort of falls apart when that
doesn't work think of him walking out of
the negotiation with nan pierce when she
tried to force him to name shiv as his
successor which is something that he
told his daughter he'd do at the
beginning of the season and then you
have to wonder if he just would have
told kendall that he thought he could
have been the ceo would he still have
followed through with the plan as it is
it makes it exciting as hell to see
kendall turn the tables and it should be
a lot of fun to see where their battle
goes from here everything is up in the
air and people are gonna have to choose
sides i think i'm most interested to see
how roman handles it and what's to
become of greg and tom now that those
documents came into play and i think
that's a great place to leave things let
me know in the comments what you took
away from the first two seasons of
succession and what you're hoping to see
in the third please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon